Fashion! It's something that genuinely interests me, and.. confuses me at the same time.
Maybe you feel the same way. Maybe you don't care. OK, great.
OK, so you're telling me, this is not confusing to you?
*Laughs*
You're telling me this? This GUCCI face mask isn't confusing to you?
Can you imagine wearing this while robbing the bank?
"Hand over all  your money??",  "But you already have so much money!" "You goddamn right I do!
*laughs*
Something i have noticed lately and maybe you have is well
It's been going for a while
fashion and memes are becoming more and
more intertwined. Gucci is the prime
example of memes and fashion coming
together. A few years ago they even did a
campaign purely based around memes to
sell their watch, and you know what it
was actually pretty good. "when he buys
you flowers instead of a GUCCI watch
Relatable!
"buy milk, call mom, wash car, new
watch, that's the thing it actually worked
worked they actually pulled it off
pretty well I have to say. I think that's
really interesting because a lot of
brands try to use memes in their
marketing as a way to appeal to a
broader audience but it rarely works.
We have so many cringe-worthy examples of
this is failing completely like Xfinity
have their... the Memestiens! "XFinity
presents the Memestiens" "I don't like
where this is going" Xfinity is crazy fast!"
"almost as me NOOB!"
"you don't know what you're doing here"
and of course the classic eating spicy
goodness LIKE A BOSS "eats spicy goodness LIKE A BOSS!" Yikes!
but probably one of the reasons why
Gucci was able to pull it off is because
memes and fashion make sense in a way
although I'll be lying if I said it didn't confuse me.
this is the first piece of clothing that shows up if you go to
GUCCI's website, GUCCI has really been
the forefront of the meve...meme movement
maybe that's not true actually but
they're one of the bigger ones. Like what is this? they're just clearly just taking the piss!
they have to be. The fall and winter
hey you want a dress like this one only
a couple grand and you can look like
this. It almost feels like a social
experiment of getting all these models
in and being like "can we trick these
models into thinking they're actually
showing off our clothes" anyhow if you
look at GUCCI maybe ten years ago you
get very different type of looks it's
very plain it's very simple it's very
clean very cut and dry their brand
represents very much how memes work it's
loud it's colorful it's obnoxious
it doesn't take itself seriously you
know what used to be a parody is now
wri... becoming reality in a way
and other brands have embraced this
fashion meme pretty literally you have
Vetements another great brand that I like
they had this famous raincoat where they
wrote literally the definition of a meme
at the back of it and their clothing
really represent the whole idea of loud
not too serious this guy literally
even looks like me what is this. *Laughs*
I thought it was so cool and so different
for having the goofy glasses when I
displayed my merch well turns out it
alter reality PewDiePie already exists
excuse me lady I think those pants are a
little too big
another another brand that embraces the
meme is Balenclaga you probably seen
these look at this dude! okay I ironicly like this one how much is it 1,500 (agh!)
Balenclaga (Igah?) which has the famous sneakers
the triple-s which are this these
gigantic colorful sneakers I remember
when I was in Japan all the.. all the
Japanese kids had these shoes, these $800
sneakers and I was so confused by it I'm
like "how did all these kids afford these
items? there's no way!" "I think whoever
designed these was just like how much
can we (blah) with sneaker heads and make
the worst shoe ever made that they still
will probably buy" cmon! I think I think
the black ones are..are pretty cool...no? alright. You probably don't care that this
is so random for me to talk about but I
do think it's very interesting how these
these brands have embraced this
different look on fashion completely and
you have these classic brands like GUCCI
and Louis Vuitton that used to be very clean
very simple only high-class people
really buy these items because they're
the only ones that can afford it and
have any reasons to buy it but now since
people want to buy into that feeling
of feel.. of being very luxurious
they don't just want to buy that but
they also want to display that you know
people people are just gonna buy an
expensive item they clearly want other
people to know that it's an expensive item
you wouldn't know that this is all
Louis Vuitton while it's pretty clear on this
outfit *Laughs* clothing really is such a huge
part of our language uhh.. the expression
is "you are what you eat" but it really
should be "you are what you consume" you
know obviously people want to associate
with these luxury brands and it's become
so popular especially with Soundcloud
rappers which are practically memes
themselves you know colorful, loud,
obnoxious, this exact same thing, uh Lil
Pump embracing GUCCI GUCCI gang even
tattooing it on himself  that's how hard
they want to be part of this brand
Savage 21 with Saint Laurent, Takeshi 6ix9ine
it's all the same thing. When me and
Marzia were in Japan we stayed there for
a month and we lived in the fashion
district so we were constantly
surrounded by people very often wearing
the exact same type of clothes or the
same brands at least I felt like I had
to buy the same type of brands because I
wanted to belong you get that feeling of
you want to be part of the group and I
think that's largely why so many kids
now are just buying into this hype beats
meme because people want to feel like
they belong they're part of it. Which
there's nothing wrong with of course I'm
not judging that I just find the
interesting of men's fashion especially
had just takes such a massive shift
because of it because usually high-class
clothing used to be so preppy but now
luxury items is available for anyone to
wear even if you're not into that type
of style they with the hypebeast it's
really more about a sporty type of look
so you can wear expensive items while
still not feeling like you're too far
off from yourself this is just me
speculating there's no hard facts here
but I think that's why hype beast has
become so popular all the kids want to
show that yes I have money when in
reality they're probably just spending
whatever money they have on these
expensive items or
asking their parents to buy it just so they can
feel like they're part of the group. I'm
not an exempt from it I feel the same
way, like I said when I was in Japan I
really was like "oh I want to buy this
because everyone else has it" you know
uh it's hard to ignore it even if you are
aware of it
supreme is such a brand example because
usually they're famous for just
literally slapping the logo on it's like
yes hello I am wearing supreme as well
how do you do and that's the thing about
memes as well that really relates to
fashion because memes is being part of a
group as well it's part of being a joke
group "hah, look we understand the same
joke" that's why memes are so obscure so
that you feel like "oh I get it
other people probably don't get it but I
get it so I I belong in this joke group"
I wonder if I could get away with
charging hundred sixty pounds for a
sweater. People were so mad at me and
Marzia for is a completely signed up our
hoodie for a hundred dollars which is
ethically produce as well which means it
cost more and and the margin that we put
on it is super fair but people got so
angry meanwhile let me just buy the
supreme like how these turtleneck with
the logo on this side are becoming more
popular now as well hmm...*Laughs* what confuses me
the absolute most about this fashion meme
movement is: who buys the stuff? Who is
buying these things like the shoes okay
alright they're crazy but they're kind
of cool I get it
but that face mask who buys that face
mask who's buying it?! okay, and that's the
thing you go here on GUCCI's website
like "okay, not my style I would not wear
any of these but then you have this and
it's like "huh that's actually pretty
cool I quite like that" how do you go
from this clean-cut and nice
all right to this is?! is that there just to
promote this is there anyone buying these?
I'm so confused
who's buying the face mask?
I don't understand! 200,000 likes I'll
buy it for a meme. I just don't get it. "But Felix it really
just all just boils down to taste"
really? really? Is that... you would... have
you seen anyone wear this?! Have you seen
anyone wearing this? It just hit me that
someone should just make a completely
meme brand and just create these obscure
clothing items but super high prices on
them and people will just buy it because
it's expensive and it's loud and it's
out there and it just hit me that's what
people are doing that's what's happening
god dammit *laughs*
alright that's all I had to say do you
agree with me? Do you disagree? don't get
me wrong though I do really like a lot
of these brands and I find it very
interesting to see this change ah
development it fascinates me because
what we decide to wear really tells a
lot about who we are for real though
I will get that facemask 200,000
likes let's get it. Alright bye!